[音楽]
こんにちはマジシャン
枝です皆さんサイコロというものをご存知
でしょうか
すごろくだったりとかなんかゲームとか
パーティーゲームボーズゲームとかする
ときによく使われるサイクロってもなんか
あるんですよはいこちらにありますねこれ
サイコロですこう1から6までの数字が
書いてあってくると数字がどれが出るわけ
ですよ
今だったら2
[拍手]
5という感じで
振ったら何かの数字が出るサイコロという
のがあるんですけれどもサイコロで何が
すぐかというと1から6の数字全部
統一の確率で出るんですよだから使われる
んですこれバラバラに振ると
全部一緒になることなんてほぼないです
サイコロ何個かまとめて振って同じ数字が
バーンてゾロ目で揃うことってすごい確率
低いんですよっぽど
確率がないと無理なんですけどもそこで皆
さんもしこのようなあなたに絶対特定の
数字しか出ないサイコロ存在したらどうし
ますよ
このサイコロ今から振りますけども
[音楽]
必ず1が出ますいきます
[拍手]
[音楽]
ちょっとまだ確定じゃないと思うので何回
か見せますね証拠
[音楽]
[拍手]
[笑い]
マジで最低最悪のイカサマサイコロです
これ特徴で作ってもらったんですけども6
の部分を重くすることによって
必ず1が出るサイコロを作りました
いたずらし放題ですよみんなで飲み会とか
して位置がやってたら飲まなきゃいけない
みたいな飲みに返しても一番軽いから
そいつに飲ませ放題ですからそんなことし
ませんけどもなんか本当に物理学的に絶対
1しか出ないようになってるんでどんな時
に振ってももう1が出ます
6で置いても1になるとここで置いても
1になっちゃうんですよこれもう本当に
やばいもん作ってたなこれこれ面白いの形
なんですよね普通のサイコロと比べてみ
たらわかると思うんですけどもちょっと
丸いんですよ回転しやすいようにちょっと
丸くなってるんでここだけ若干不自然です
けどもまサイコロなんていろんな形がある
んでそんなに気になんないと思います
やばくないですかこれそして今回なんと
この
必ず1が出るサイコロ110で100個
準備しました1回全部出しときますねこれ
全部1しか出ませんもうこうやって適当に
おいても
適当に置いても1位になっちゃうんですよ
あなたあ戻ったというわけで皆さん例えば
今からサイコロ100個投げて全部1が出
ないと終わりませんと企画やりますこの
動画のタイトルになってるかもしれません
嘘じゃないのでいきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
えーっと見ますね見ますね
11111111111111
クリアーなんて子供できるんですね
ちょっとこれを使ってうまいのやつらに
特定していきたいと思います
本当に密集すると転がれなくてこうやって
4とかになるやつもいるんでちょっと怖い
なそこだけだな結構バランスよく投げれば
いけますというわけでドッキリやっていき
ましょう
[音楽]
いらっしゃいますいらっしゃいますここに
サイコロがございます
[音楽]
今から100個同時に投げて全部ゾロ目で
1が出るか出ないかどっちだと思います
全部ゾロ目で1が出るか出ないか100回
で100回だけ100回
出たらどうします出たら全部1出たらです
よね一緒に痩せや行きますそれはやめとか
いきますねお願いします100
回あるのね
いきます
[拍手]
絶対するよこれ
絶対するって
これあれでもあれでもん
おーいやつじゃないですかこれうわ
[音楽]
ー
飲み会で使う絶対使う
[音楽]
ようこそ大地さんお待たせしました
今日は大すぎるといきましょう
どうしよう
ゾロ目出したら勝ちとろめ先に出した方が
勝ちですね
どうぞいきますよ
はい
よしよし353か
僕がしていただきます
いきます
[拍手]
うわ1条シャア
よし
よしよし
[音楽]
もう一回
[拍手]
うわぁ
惜しいですよお姉ちゃんいきますね
[音楽]
よし
マジで1個増やしてみるじゃん
よってそのことはなかなかないですから
これだってもう何分のないよね
はいあー
惜しい
とりあえず行きますねいきますはい
はいやってるやってますねこれ
すごいな今日マジでマジ
俺
ランチくんのそれ
大事かなそれです
[音楽]
[拍手]
今なんか
[音楽]
[拍手]
なんで今の動きください
[音楽]
なやば
史上最悪のイカサマ大好き作りましたやば
1が必ず1が必ず出るよね何があろうと
すごいあのこれや
[笑い]
ばー
これをこうやって投げると
[拍手]
全部1だ
すげえ
[拍手]
ダルメシアみたいな
お疲れ
[音楽]
様ですサイコロ
何すかこれ
どういうこと
えどういうこと
[音楽]
はい
いつしか出ないサイコロだやば